hey guys merry here with your gamespot
re-release news update of the week this
week we got a scorcher for you it's
Borderlands the pre-sequel in
Borderlands 2 coming out on xbox one and
ps4 it's going to be good it's going to
be new hoots someone will give a [ __ ]
Borderlands the handsome collection will
contain all of the DLC from Borderlands
2 and the pre-sequel it's scheduled to
launch in North America on march 24th
followed by an international release on
the 27th xbox 360 players will be able
to transfer their saved Xbox one and ps3
to ps4 got to keep it within the family
according to the PlayStation Blog the
handsome collection has both games
running in gorgeous HD and looking
pretty damn great at a resolution and
performance level like never before seen
in borderlands on consoles but possibly
seen before if you've ever played it on
PC perhaps the most exciting feature Who
am I kidding the most exciting feature
coming to the handsome collection is the
inclusion of four player splitscreen an
option that hasn't been very common on
current-gen systems 2k and gearbox also
revealed a claptrap in a box edition of
the game available to pre-order but act
quickly if you give a [ __ ] because only
5,000 units will be available worldwide
it includes a copy of the handsome
collection a remote-controlled claptrap
steward steel case and 12 lithographs
for player splitscreen actually sounds
pretty cool what do you guys think you
can sound off in the comments below and
be sure to check out gamespot com / news
for all your remaster and re-release
needs